hey what's going on it's bill burr and
it's time for the Monday morning podcast
for Monday February 26 2018 how's it
going how are ya are you enjoying your
february of 2018 well you should because
you never know you never know if there's
gonna be another february of 2018
nothing is promised just remember to
look up with the clouds today and smile
sorry I'm threatening to get on
Instagram once again and I'm gonna get
on there and I'm gonna become someone
who's in the public eye that inspires
you so I just want to try out some of my
inspiring words you know my wife my
laughs she's on Instagram and I always
look at those things it always cracks me
up people sit there they act like
they're trying to inspire you and it's
really just an excuse so they can take
their shirt off and show you like how
great a shape they're in
always set goals beyond your own belief
in yourself cuz even if you fall short
you're still in the money round whatever
the fire can have a finishing you don't
to me then they're just sitting they
were like [ __ ] eight pack abs you
know but like with a hat on like a
[ __ ] knitted hat it's like dude I
thought you're cold when you put a shirt
on him all right he starts off being
Kunti and it's only gonna get more Kunti
from there so I was out in I was out in
Santa Monica and I was coming back
towards Hollywood you know to get my my
Botox injections a lot of people don't
know that about myself that I'm actually
I've lied to you all of these years I'm
actually 63 years old and I take a very
high quality Botox injection every every
third day sort of like the patron silver
of like Botox you know I don't know [ __ ]
about tequila I'm sure somebody's gonna
say actually that's clear
the mid-range tequila lugar B no one
cares no one cares about you and your
[ __ ] tequila connoisseur e so anyway
so I'm driving into Hollywood right and
I stopped at a red light and there's all
these these throw Second Amendment
people stand-in there right with like
megaphones and [ __ ] and they just keep
yelling like literally some of the
dumbest [ __ ] people I've ever seen in
my life
and that my friend is what always now
now now if I was a [ __ ] which I am I
would look at those people be like yes
that's what people who defend the Second
Amendment look like rather than being
like no people who [ __ ] are gonna
stand at a [ __ ] red light with a
bullhorn there's a certain level of
intellect that that's going to have and
there it is you know what I mean
it's kind of like one like the left goes
out and they protest something like over
that I always bring this cheer that
check up the [ __ ] sat there when
Trump was getting sworn in and she was
good
that [ __ ] like what sort of balance
conversation could you have with the
human being like that and it's just same
like these VLAN I just
it was [ __ ] hilarious and then people
were beeping at them yeah I don't you
can't tell when someone hits so horn
whether it's they don't have like the
the positive beeping I guess that's like
a peep you can't tell if they were
beeping like yeah keep yelling that [ __ ]
that doesn't make any sense I don't
understand America love it or leave it
so if you want to adjust anything then
you need to get the [ __ ] out of here
like it's just like I mean that's what
the Flyers did for the last [ __ ] 40
years and that's why they have yet to
win another Cup because whatever they
did in 74 and 75 they continued to
[ __ ] do up until about maybe six or
seven seasons ago you know oh are you
gonna beat the [ __ ] out of people right
that worked in 74 and 75 before social
media before Millennials were even born
you could do that alright and they
didn't adjust and look at them now cup
'less J won a Stanley Cup since Gerald
Ford was in office and that's [ __ ]
unbelievable right actually it really
isn't when you look at it there's there
is 30 teams if you win one once every 30
years that's pretty much average so
they're a little behind the little
buying the curve they need to stay off
the class get a little extra help on how
to cycle it around yeah and I love how
there's these [ __ ] morons that go and
love it or leave it and what the
defending was an amendment to the
Constitution which is it change [ __ ]
unbelievable and the look on their face
to when they were pissing people off
because like these [ __ ] morons were
actually looking at him getting mad I
actually rolled my window down because I
want to call one of the guys fat I just
looked at it like this is this is gonna
be how mad could I make this guy it's so
childish but that's how it kind of
looked at it but
I did the look on their faces of them
just pissing people off they had total
joy on their faces so it's just like
you're not making it any better you're
actually making it worse I don't know
why can't people just just sit down and
just be like like you know the people on
the defend ar-15s can be like look and
then the people on the Left can be like
excuse me is that a butterfly one of
those goods maybe that's what we need to
do maybe maybe that's the way that each
side can hear each other each side
performs as the stereotype you know or
wait maybe you present your liberal
opinion and your your viewpoint of what
you think the right sounds like you know
right and then they have to clear my
name refute they have to be like you
anyways I fell my god I have never
gotten more goddamn responses though
when you start bringing up [ __ ] guns
there's gotta be how can you do it like
you know you gotta let these [ __ ]
people still have their machine guns so
they can get out there and then
four-wheelers or you know who knows
who knows what's gonna happen I am
curious too as far as um well before I
finish the how do you figure out who's a
[ __ ] lunatic and who is it you don't I
mean because the III haven't done any
research on this but I would be willing
to bet that at least 98 percent of
registered gun owners are [ __ ]
responsible you know they're out there
shooting squirrels off their balconies
right with that gun you can you see at
the end of scarf
so whatever the [ __ ] it is it doe gives
a [ __ ] that's all they're doing just the
[ __ ] squirrel man's goddamn cute rat
as far as I'm concerned good ain't no
it's good eating it's like a gamey
chicken with a little bit of a Captain
Crunch in it it's got to be a way to uh
you know you know I mean I don't think
anybody who owns a gun thinks that some
[ __ ] lunatic should get a gun like
that so why don't we just work on what
work on that how would you do that how
would you possibly [ __ ] do that I
don't know I actually got it intuitive
somebody you know and they they were
trying to tell me that silencers were
legal in New York and I'm like dude
they're not he's like yes they are and I
said dude I lived there they're not and
then he's like immediately he goes they
are you just have to register so then I
google it and it says that suppressors
are legal in like some like 42 different
states and one of the states they
weren't legal in was New York and then
the guy gets rather than being like okay
I'm wrong he gets like [ __ ] mad he
goes was that a new law it's like no I
don't know I don't know when it came far
as I know whatever I [ __ ] lived there
you can't have a silencer in [ __ ] in New
York City that basically means that I'm
gonna go assassinate somebody it's not
like we have a bunch of [ __ ] coyotes
and [ __ ] running around alligators and
that top [ __ ] because in Florida they
were just like well you know cuz we shot
guns with silencers in Florida they
would just go and we were laughing and
virzi said yeah having a silencer in New
York means I basically want to kill
somebody I don't want anybody to hear it
and they laughed and down here they were
like oh that just down here that just
means there's an alligator on your yard
you don't want to wake up your neighbor
you know so it's like oh all right I get
it
plus my ears are junk I think if I had a
[ __ ] gun I would want to have a
suppressor you know I mean that's got to
be the bits got to be the best if
somebody breaks into your house all
right and your gun is readily available
and you have a suppressor on it right
and you just [ __ ] stand up being your
jamjam square
in your ass and you just yeah I'll clean
that up in the morning you just go right
back to bed
you know and you just lay in there you
know you did something [ __ ] up the
night before you're not you know how you
wake up well you don't just sort of
gradually wake up your [ __ ] eyes just
come open - I just don't [ __ ] [ __ ] so
I have to shoot some bow - last night I
got dammit the Bloods all dried on the
floor
anyways I find the whole [ __ ] thing
fascinating I also find it fascinating
that you know as much as I'm a believer
that you shouldn't the government
shouldn't be the only one that has guns
it's like too much powers considering
what the [ __ ] they're doing I also don't
I think for as far as technology goes an
owner of media I just don't think that a
bunch of people with like guns in their
houses is going to stop any sort of
[ __ ] you know if we went I don't know
how much crazy we could get in this
country but if we really went totally
[ __ ] crazy I really don't think a
bunch of armed citizens who are not
organized or even remotely have the
training or the weaponry of what you
know the martial law whatever the [ __ ]
would be enacted would even be able to
stop it you know and then the people
that took over and power would also
control the media and then they would
they would put out information to make
those patriotic citizens look like they
were [ __ ] Nazis and the whole thing
would fall apart
however you know for a lot of people I
think it would be a fun way to go out
you want my guns come and get him go get
him
you want my soul cycle well I'm gonna
put it up a Craigslist next week alright
let's get out of this [ __ ] topic
we'll talk about it later
I'm trying to be even here like sort of
trashing both sides and seeing both
sides you know this is my Instagram
inspirational thing on gun control I'm
trying to see both sides of this in the
end of this I will take my shirt off
it's not even that people in the public
eye do that it's the people that follow
them
I guess if they are inspiring them I
guess they are doing something but it is
just so clearly it has nothing to do
even if they inspires somebody that's
even more for that person that took
their shirt off to [ __ ] feed their
ego anyways or maybe I just never looked
good with my shirt off in shape or out
of shape because I was so pasty white
you know I felt bad for [ __ ] that was
a fellow celebrity a redhead and he had
his shirt off on a boat and everyone was
you know and he's in great shape and
that's all everybody talked about was
how [ __ ] white he was you know if
redheads ever had a bodybuilding contest
what it would basically they would do it
for the blind then the blind would just
come up like touching their torso and be
like okay it could be this could be a
little more defined
you know we'd sit there with our angry
freckled fingers you know giving them
the finger maybe I have no idea all I
know is that since I've become a dad I
you know I don't have time to [ __ ]
watch games the way I used to especially
like hockey and basketball how how many
games there are and all that every time
I [ __ ] start to get caught up on the
Bruins I look at my little thing you
know says you have five new games to
watch and I know they're playing great
and they're making all these moves I
don't know if this trade went through
but we got [ __ ] Rick Nash from the
ranges that I was thinking out god like
who the [ __ ] did we give up for this guy
and we gave up a first-round draft pick
who the hell is it here and we gave up
we gave up Ryan Spooner and Matt poleski
matter Rick Nash is 33
I love Ryan Spooner um oh well what are
you gonna do what are you gonna do but I
I think who knows I like what Sweeney's
doing he's just like all right [ __ ] it
we're we're like right there let's push
this over the top it gives us a physical
presence a guy that gives you 30 calls a
season I think the Bruins definitely got
better they're gonna put him on the
second line with David Krejci now you
got Bergeron yeah you got posture knock
you got you got you got Marshawn in the
first slide that gives us two really
solid lines and I haven't watched that
many games issues but the game have
games I've been watching our fourth line
actually kind of contributes quite a bit
we're young were fast now we got this
guy and he's uh he's a big presence out
there he doesn't really drop the gloves
but I mean that's been completely taken
out of the game by the way people who
always talk about how much they love
Olympic hockey and if they could just
get the fighting out of a gel that they
would actually sit down and watch it
well all I want to say is [ __ ] you you
lyin [ __ ] because you ruined the game
that I loved because they pretty much
got fighting out of the game certainly
in the playoffs you get in the playoffs
the goons are gone the goons go home the
goons go home at night the goons go home
at night they go home at during the
[ __ ] playoffs they sent him all home
and every year I get a little sad you
know when I see that and I think back to
the 80s when the [ __ ] Bruins played
the [ __ ] Buffalo Sabres and it was
standing room only in the penalty box
it's like two guys sitting down three
people standing up behind him look like
they was stuck in an elevator back then
that was called setting the tone that's
not what happens anymore is it
uh-huh all these people out there trying
to take away my guns and my poor Wailers
sorry all these people out there trying
to take my gun my four-wheeler
[ __ ] liberal snowflake why don't you
just skip to some socialist country well
let me tell you something there's no
room for violence in hockey
it just shows ignorance okay that's what
I'm gonna do from here on out whenever I
present the liberal side I'm gonna try
to do I'm gonna do a [ __ ] I need
another good liberal argument you know
what I mean I don't know why the [ __ ] we
just don't switch over to solar power
all these stupid [ __ ] rednecks rollin
cold
they should have solar power these
[ __ ] oil companies and corporations
they don't want to do it America I love
it or leave it
or adjust it you know as eight as
everything does as everything in the
world does as it moves forward it
adjusts you know as virus adjusts adjust
I should say adjust adjust
we're all using that hand sanitizer and
all that [ __ ] you know one of the virus
is doing going well I guess that's it
for us I guess we can't kill any more
people they're not there Hannah Jim that
drinking that [ __ ] up and they're
getting even stronger and there's a
there's gonna be a [ __ ] look at look
how strong the fluids look I mean
[ __ ] kids died this shit's terrifying
everything adjusts alright you can't
adjust [ __ ] you know amendments are
adjustments to the Constitution get dumb
[ __ ] over there I mean I'm not saying
I'm not saying you shouldn't defend your
girl I'm gonna be liberal here I'm not
saying here and defend your guns I'm
just saying some adjustments maybe need
to be made you know
I don't remember I almost said Tom
Sawyer I don't remember who's the guy
who said the British are coming
Paul Revere I don't remember his kid
going into a log cabin you know shooting
up with a musket all right what do we
got here hand sanitizer super virus
super super super super super you guys
might be super foes and when that came
up to your cable station I have the
worst [ __ ] goddamn internet he has
the worst [ __ ] Internet in the world
but up but up a pata pata pata pata papa
okay fact or fiction can hand sanitizer
use create a superbug hand sanitizer
dispensers are mounted everywhere in
office buildings restaurants schools and
hospitals in case you didn't know what
everywhere meant we can carry bottles of
it in our purses and on our keychains
there we've covered male and female
behavior but we but are we using it
correctly and can it use be used to make
a superbug
USA Today Network reviews facts and
fiction surrounding hand sanitizer myths
kids who suck their thumbs shouldn't use
hand sanitizer it's generally okay to
apply hand sanitizer on a child oh geez
that just covered themselves legally
generally it's okay my kid just died
well we didn't say totally a taste a
taste amount from the hand is not
usually a problem
Nicole weed a registered nurse and a
certified specialist in poison
information told USA Today Network at
most there may be some irritation in the
mouth from the alcohol-based products do
keep an eye on kids though [ __ ] you so
goddamn advertisement there we go
hand sanitizers often smells good and
comes in bright colored packages that's
attractive to children ingesting a large
amount of it could make them very sick
she said or shit-faced depending
what brand you use myth sort of myth
sort of using hand sanitizer can use the
create can lead to the creation of
superbugs the concern about superbugs
centers around a chemical ingredient
found in many antibacterial products
called tri co-sin try Co Sam is not
found in most hand sanitizers but it is
found in many antibacterial hand soaps
and cleaners recent studies have found
that the chemical may alter the way
hormones work in the body according to
federal drug abuse to bacterial
resistance to antibiotics or superbugs
tri-state regime is not considered an
essential agreement for many products
and its use is currently under review by
the FDA and the Environmental Protection
Agency the FDA is also made up of a
bunch of people that used to work in the
industries that they're supposed to be
policing so who knows alright this is
why I am a [ __ ] because there's a bunch
of other facts I don't know what the
facts I just get bored but listen this
is why I I don't read a lot of [ __ ]
because I'm reading this on USA Today
and then USA Today just has a bunch of
like clickbait like underneath remember
Katherine Bell from jag see where she is
now Google may not show you this enter
any name this is on the USA Today site
this is supposed to be like a [ __ ]
reputable newspaper top five local solar
companies check out best and worst
reviews I want solar panels don't one
one big one right on my forehead right
alright blown head yeah okay you know
what the greatest thing about my
daughter is right now besides everything
is she gives hugs now like legit hugs
right like I opened the door to a room
today she was in there talking to
herself up in the dorm rooms just goes
high okay so I start cracking up my Chi
and I walk over to pick her up I pick
her up she grabs like
around my neck Shin behind my neck she
grabs like a handful on my shirt like I
owe her money you know and then the
other hand is just sort of on my
shoulder and she pulls herself into me
with their head right up against my head
and I'm standing like are you kidding me
this is the greatest thing ever and
after like just squeezing me for like a
good five the best five seconds of my
life
she then lets up and then gave me a kiss
and then went and hugged me again it was
so awesome
I literally re-enacted it to my laugh I
was like this is what she did this
morning the best part is they hand full
of this shirt or maybe the feeling of
this the side of their face on yours I
don't know what but all I can tell you
this is the greatest thing ever it's
becoming a dad it's awesome you know I
know there's the lack of sleep I know
your sex life goes out the [ __ ]
window but it's worth it
it's totally [ __ ] worth it all right
oh Jesus
here we go we got we have one read one
race in the barren landscape The Walking
Dead that is my [ __ ] advertisers
lately all right oh look who we see
everybody it's old zip talk about the
challenge of finding great talent and
how the way you went about it just did
not work always inefficient well you
know today I was at a red light and I
saw a bunch of people standing around
megaphones I was like whoa
they gotta say anyway and I was like oh
my god what dumb look I just not a bunch
of talented people but I had to get in
my car to do it I had to get him a truck
to go do it my forward or truck with the
bedliner you know if I had ol zip
recruiter I could have just done this at
home all right zip recruiter knew there
were there was a smarter way so they
built a platform that finds the right
job candidates for you
zip learns what you're looking for
identifies people with the right
experience and invites them to apply to
your job
these invitation have revolutionized how
you find your next hire in fact 80% of
employees who post jobs on zip get a
quality candidate through the site in
just one day and zip recruiters does not
stop there they even spotlight the
strongest applications you receive so
you never miss a great match the right
candidates are out there zip recruiter
is how you find them business is boss of
all sizes trust for hiring needs right
now my listeners can try zip recruiter
for free that's free just go to zip
dot-com / / that zip recruiter comp / /
the smartest way to hire it's the
smartest way to hire Oh guess what
so it's mentioned as mentioned old
freckles hey there freckle face running
under a tree because you don't want a
sunburn getting the [ __ ] kicked out of
you every outdoor recess where's a
teacher when you need one is turning 50
the big 500 those [ __ ] people they
drop me - I think I remember they're
just hanging out maybe this dead lean in
the weeds 50 years old I'm turnin so I
have to go to the doctor I've decided
that I'm actually going to get a doctor
alright I'm gonna go in there and I'll
be like alright light me up let's see
take some x-rays
check out my heart I'm doing all of that
[ __ ] right after a half a [ __ ]
century running around eating [ __ ]
burgers and bologna sandwiches and [ __ ]
I'm gonna see how much damage I've done
to myself and hopefully they won't find
anything and if they do hopefully they
can fix it and that out that'll be good
I'll get a little you know get a little
freshen up here you know got my teeth
all straightened out here ready to read
the [ __ ] news I'm telling you right
now Connie Chung has nothing on me did
she have nice teeth I don't [ __ ]
remember anyways yes I'm gonna go in
there I'm gonna get my heart liver oh
Jesus
stomach pancreas the whole goddamn think
at least the whole [ __ ] thing right
hey what was that movie that guy was it
well they flew this spaceship around
inside the person's body the [ __ ] was
that called come on Edie you're just not
alright I'm gonna get my ears checked
out - what is hey Mia what's the name of
that movie that that Dennis Quaid was in
where he was flying around inside
somebody's body in our space yeah I got
to get that [ __ ] procedure you know
when you turn 50 now they got to do that
right they got to do the [ __ ] IMAX up
your ass camera up your ass inner space
I have to do all of that [ __ ] it's
[ __ ] you know how did this happen I
used to be a young man but whatever I'm
gonna go [ __ ] do it because because I
got the little kid you know if I didn't
have the kid you know I think I just
sort of drink myself to death you know
you know what I would love to do if I
didn't have any responsibilities what I
was seeing those people standing there
doing that America over relieve it
but you just had a lawn chair I could
have just
at a tree across the street you know
with a nice [ __ ] adult beverage you
know and I have to have a mixer though
right in case the cops came by officer
I'm just drinking lemonade it's gluten
free and just sit there watching the
boobs part of me that actually enjoyed
watching them come down like hey let's
go down there and piss off a bunch of
liberals and they come down and I just
don't think that they made the problem
better
they didn't make anybody on the left
want to listen to what the [ __ ] they had
to say but they were morons and I don't
think everybody on the right is like
that I don't think everybody on the left
is a [ __ ] lunatic one of them hairy
leg bloated takes over they're trying to
[ __ ] change everything that we hold
dear
no nose who the [ __ ] knows all right
we're a half-hour in here I got a bunch
of [ __ ] to do today dude my drum
room is done and I can't even [ __ ]
tell you well I'm gonna tell I'm gonna
try to tell you about how [ __ ]
awesome it is the first time in my life
I can play drums as loud as I want and
not piss anybody off okay if you like me
okay if it's just a hobby and every time
you go to play somebody tells you to
shut the [ __ ] up and you always think
why didn't I just play the ukelele
why did I have to pick this instrument
I'm going to tell you right now you need
to you need to get a drum room I don't
give a [ __ ] how you do it just you know
I was actually thinking you know if this
thing didn't work what I was gonna do I
was just gonna pay somebody to literally
dig a [ __ ] hole in the ground like a
bomb shelter all right and just stick
the whole [ __ ] thing under the ground
right put some cinder blocks make a
little room and you literally have to go
down a ladder into the [ __ ] thing and
then of course I don't stop there I'm
like what if I had a tunnel going from
the [ __ ] house like Al Capone and I
could just walk in like that you have it
underneath you know the taxman can't see
it so he can't tax you for it you know
and then this is think some day you sell
the house and you don't tell anybody
that it's there
then one day somebody discovers it and
then they're filming it and they're all
[ __ ] excited to see all what's gonna
be down there is there gonna be a safe
is it gonna be a dead body is there
gonna be a pterodactyl egg from
prehistoric times yeah they go down
there it's just some big stupid drum
room all right pictures of Fred Curie
and Rikki Rockett Tommy Lee Nicko
McBrain all these people that I grew up
watching Phil Rudd I'd leave the posters
I don't have posters of reading those
people all right let's do and I've
actually because because of my shoulder
which I'm telling you and I got it up to
about 85 percent here and I just can't
[ __ ] it up by whaling on the drums I've
just been working on my feet and just
the [ __ ] bands that I'm getting into
because I've just been listening to a
lot of double bass now and my younger
brothers were always into like Pantera
and [ __ ] and I was just like that's too
heavy for me I can't believe I didn't
die I could no I was old enough I could
have saw that band and I didn't but I've
just gone [ __ ] got like everything
that they have now and I always knew
Vinnie Paul was a [ __ ] great doughnut
but Jesus Christ this incredible
incredible [ __ ] drummer and cowboys
from hell and I'm broken up probably my
two favorites and somebody my drum
teacher told me about their live album
that 101 proof and just how they end
broken with that little double bass
[ __ ] riff there in the end it's just
like I wanted to learn how to [ __ ] now
I'm gonna do that my drum room and
that's it that's what the [ __ ] I've been
doing I've been doing that and working
on the that Meshuggah bleed so that's I
do I'm going to start double bass with
them probably the most difficult double
bass song you could possibly have I'm up
to about
70 bpm being able to play that lick with
playing eighth notes like butta butta
butta butta played like that it's not
going as fast it's more like that it
that it that it that it that it that it
and that's what I do okay now if you
learn how [ __ ] boring my actual life
is other than when my kid gives me a hug
in the morning alright 34 [ __ ] minutes
in let's see if I can [ __ ] [ __ ]
for another 26 minutes here oh by the
way they added a show there's a third
show that I'm trying to sell up there in
Van [ __ ] I'm gonna be up there on March
7th and March 8th which is going to be
it's going to be so much [ __ ] fun I
can't wait and I I'm like chomping at
the bit to start my road gigs first of
all you know I haven't worked that much
this year so far and you know the bills
keep coming in you know what I mean you
know the wife keeps spending money the
kid needs something everybody's [ __ ]
you know here's this fee for this here's
this fee for [ __ ] that this is a
processing fee and all that next thing
you know they just deplete your [ __ ]
phone I have no [ __ ] idea how anybody
ever retires but I understand why when
you do you eat [ __ ] dog food just
trying to stretch every goddamn nickel
you can't go and how long am I gonna
live how long do I have to stretch this
out all right sheriff [ __ ] this is
what's just what somebody wrote him okay
now that I've brought up you know
talking about guns and that type of
thing trying to keep everybody calm and
relaxed and have a nice conversation or
we can somehow try to find a solution
because God knows if smart people
couldn't come up with a solution I think
it's time for someone of my intellect
with the podcast laying here talking to
nobody to come up with the solution
this is like when a celebrity says that
they're gonna run for president what I'm
doing here this is what happens all
right sheriff [ __ ] bill
I'll tell you who's a [ __ ] the sheriff
from that town you got to see this guy
doing interviews I love how this person
writes the sheriff from that town like
what town you just literally you [ __ ]
had half the conversation already in
your head
bill I'll tell you who's a [ __ ] up the
sheriff from that [ __ ] town you got
to see this guy doing interviews he he
talks oh my god he talks like a Long
Island Jew who runs a deli oh boy how
dumb is this person there's a great way
to make a point and say something
anti-semitic right out of the gate
that'll make people listen he went on
CNN and started calling for gun control
to take away attention from the fact
that he had deputies puss out and not
engaged the shooter all right I did read
that there was stuff like that there was
allegedly stuff like that going on and
let me guess buddy you would have ran
right in there right with your [ __ ]
9-millimeter would you would you would
you [ __ ] pull a nine-millimeter on a
guy who had a [ __ ] ar-15 would you
[ __ ] do I'm just asking you that huh
and if you would then what do you need
an ar-15 for you're evidently not afraid
there's a lot of people that [ __ ]
freeze up and you never know what you're
gonna do in that time all of a sudden
you start thinking of your kid who knows
it's very easy to sit there be like well
these [ __ ] people they [ __ ] good
you know you know what I would have done
they did the same thing a cop who shoots
an innocent black guy did in the sense
that they were not ready for the job
they had the uniform and an idea that
they were someone who could handle this
they weren't dude this is all a legend
the Sheriff's Office and the shitty FBI
[ __ ] blew it when it came to all the
warnings I've read that too I don't
believe in taking every gun but how
about not letting a delinquent kid buy a
[ __ ] semi-automatic rifle along with
some stricter [ __ ] in place we need
people who can do their [ __ ] job you
know if you take away the anti-semitism
in that I actually agree with most of
that yeah like if I everything that
they're saying is true that the people
people like literally said this kids is
threatening to shoot up a school he's
taking pictures of himself with guns on
instance I just can't believe yet
another kid did that there was all these
warning signs and people were still
allegedly ignoring it if that is the
case you know what I mean is it cuz it's
guns I don't know what it is if somebody
was on Instagram going you know I'm
gonna take my dick out at school they
were standing there with holding their
[ __ ] dick shaking it right
I mean how [ __ ] long would you last
you will be over they'd be [ __ ] over
wouldn't it I mean what do these people
have to do in a way isn't that like a
cry for help
all right guns are fun exclamation point
my dearest mr. burr I grew up in rural
Washington State with guns in the house
and went to school with kids who had gun
racks in their trucks and one hunting
after school sounds like the beginning
of Red Dawn as an adult I never owned a
gun since I don't hunt and I live in a
city with police minutes away so I feel
like I can see both sides of the issue
now there's a great [ __ ] point with
police minutes away provided you're
white they're minutes away and they will
help you provide it your way I'm [ __ ]
around before shut the [ __ ] up I'm
allowed to make jokes here yeah I get
that I get that because that is the
feeling I always understood owning a gun
whenever I did like college gigs and bro
gigs that were in the middle of nowhere
like you just drive by some little farm
house some little [ __ ] house in the
middle of nowhere and you're just like
this what is to stop anybody from just
driving up that driveway no matter how
loud you scream for help no one was
gonna hear it alright anyways he says
anyway this guy goes that being said I
don't think the system of
we have now is working and I think we
could do better now I don't think
anybody can argue that whatever system
we have is not working because I'm
saying it's not working doesn't mean I'm
saying that they now have to [ __ ]
outlaw certain guns or whatever I'm just
saying that you know if somebody is
literally saying I'm going to shoot up a
[ __ ] school or making threats like
that while with taking pictures of
themselves with guns and then people
bring that to the authorities allegedly
and nothing was done yet this something
not working all right my ideas are as
follows one people who want to hunt can
have both bolt-action hunting rifles one
shot one kill
bye-bye Bambi mommy wants some venison
steaks all right
you went a lot better with the reference
to references there
why Bambi you know why wouldn't you
shoot the mother so then Bambi has no
mom isn't that how it's supposed that's
the way Disney did it all right people
who want to protect their homes can have
shotguns for the spread obviously
well the one thing about the spread is
like what if they've already grabbed
your [ __ ] kid you know I don't know
that's a tough [ __ ] thing to like to
shoot a gun in your house you want
enough firepower to kill somebody but
you don't want it to go through them
through a wall and into somebody else
that you actually like or maybe
tolerating you know if you have in-laws
living with you right into the other
room and then you got to deal with that
for the rest you laugh you know
something your whole [ __ ] family's
crazy I don't know why Hawai I ever
married any of these people I should
have known it man you [ __ ] whole
family had one pair of [ __ ] shoes all
right number three
all right pistols only for cops security
guards or other people who have a
credible reason that involves the need
to occasionally shoot someone I
that's how they do it in Australia not
sure too lazy to confirm alright I like
the honesty of that this all makes sense
but it's also like what about bad people
who don't give a [ __ ] about loss and
then everybody turns in their God oh no
and you live in the middle of nowhere
and you turn in your [ __ ] gun and
then the douchebag who wants to rob you
doesn't then one all right number three
people who want to have fun and blow
[ __ ] up can own whatever the [ __ ] they
want but it has to be delivered and kept
at a licensed gun range at all times gun
ranges could become the new golf course
this guy's got some interesting ideas
show up with your buddies or the ladies
rent a [ __ ] machine gun and have a
blast shoot up a bunch of paper targets
dummies that look like monsters or even
shoot up some burned-out cars doesn't
matter you having fun safety and
responsibility in a controlled
environment just some ideas nothing too
crazy I hope go [ __ ] yourself safely and
responsibly of course I like a lot of
that the flying the [ __ ] ointment and
all of this is people that aren't going
to comply with it you know and then
everybody's going to turn in their
[ __ ] guns and comply with all that
except for like criminals or whatever
but then it doesn't say anything that
you can't have a sword what if you
booby-trap your house I don't know what
are the word what are the odds that
someone's gonna come into your house I
have no idea I don't [ __ ] know I'm
kind of believe that now that they're
out there I don't know how you [ __ ]
bring it back all this is doing it's
just you know what it is because there's
always like the what if and all of that
because if we did have it like that like
you know you go to England the cops
don't even have guns they just come up
and they just swarm around you and they
just sort of Club you but the people
walking around don't really have guns
as far as I know I don't know isn't it
funny that I just don't look anything up
and I just start talking gun violence in
England let's see what this brings up
gun crime in London increases by 42% gun
violence rare in UK compared to the US
well it's because were the best at
everything
[Music]
if London was better at get [ __ ] if
England was better at gun violence we'd
still be under their [ __ ] rule right
all right gun crime in London increases
by 42% this is a baby seat knows oh wait
they you know something because of
terrorism now they have all the good the
met police said there was complex social
reasons why more young people are
carrying knives all right we went from
guns to knife gun crimes in London's
surged by 42% in the last year according
to official statistics the Met police's
figure shows that there were 2,500 44
gun crime offences from April to 6 2016
to April 2017 compared to 1793 offences
from 2015 until 2016
alright so I mean essentially you know
and it's kind of like [ __ ] what would
that be that's about six incidents a day
no less than that five four and a half
that's pretty good for a whole city
though right knife crime also increased
by 24% with 12,000 seventy-four recorded
offences from 2016 to 2017 the Med said
although crime rates were rising they
remained at a much lower level level
than five years ago
Scotland yea registered annual rises
across a number of serious offensive
category offense offense categories in
the past 12 months
buh-buh-buh
okay all right I don't know what I just
learned there I have no idea oh and then
on the side they have blind MMA champion
takes on a new takes on new fight the
American who fled gay conversation in
Africa everybody just has clickbait mums
bullying campaign leads to honesty
honesty app banned immigration dominates
Italian election there's a decent story
breakthrough breakthroughs take time to
sell rare photographs that change lives
oh boy all right what are we doing here
okay let's go back to whatever the [ __ ]
I was just really all right a
radiologist explains why a bullet from
an ar-15 is so lethal
was anybody questioning I just thought
that kind of bounced off you okay hey
Bill love what you do and you are an
amazing asset to the community
oh you buttered me up I'm definitely
gonna read this I recently found this
article from the viewpoint of a
radiologist concerning the power of an
ar-15 you're usually don't hear the
viewpoints from people in the medical
field it's the viewpoint that makes this
piece unique and joy all right go to the
page okay here we go
what I saw treating the victims from
Parkland should change the debate on
guns they weren't the Matt first mass
shooting victims the Florida Florida
radiologist saw but the wounds were
radically different as I opened the CT
scan last week to read the next case I
was baffled the history simply read
gunshot wound I had been a radiologist
and one of the busiest trauma centers in
the United States for thirteen years and
in diagnosed thousands of handgun
injuries to the brain lung liver spleen
bowel
and vital organ organs I thought that I
knew that all that I needed to know
about gunshot wounds but the specific
pattern of injury injury on my computer
screen was one that I had only seen once
before in a typical handgun injury which
I diagnosed almost daily a bullet leaves
a laceration through an organ such as
the liver to a radiologist it appears as
a linear thin gray bullet track through
the organ there may be bleeding in some
bullet fragments I was looking at a CT
scan of one of the mass shooting victims
from the Marjorie Stoneham Douglass High
School hope I said that right
did I see a majority earlier who had
been brought to the trauma center during
my call shift the organ looked like an
overripe melon smashed by a sledgehammer
and was bleeding extensively how could a
gunshot won't cause this much damage the
reaction in the emergency room was the
same one of the trauma surgeons opened a
young victims in the operating room and
found only shreds of the organ that had
been hit by the bullet from an ar-15 a
semiotic rifle that delivers a
devastatingly lethal high-velocity
bullet to the victim nothing was left to
repair and utterly devastating nothing
could be done to fix the problem the
injury was fatal a year ago when a
gunman opened fire at the Fort
Lauderdale Airport with a
nine-millimeter semi-automatic handgun
hitting 11 people in 90 seconds I was on
call it was not until I had diagnosed
the third third of the six victims who
were transported to the trauma center
that I realized something out of the
ordinary must have happened the gunshots
wounds were the same low-level velocity
handgun injuries that I diagnosed every
day only rapid succession set them apart
and all six of the victims who arrived
at the hospital that day survived
routine handgun injuries leave entry and
exit wounds and linear tracks through
the victims body that are roughly the
size of the bullet the bullet does not
directly hit something crucial like the
heart or the aorta the victim does not
bleed to death before being transported
to care at the trauma center chances are
that we can save them the bullet is
fired by an air
fifteen are different they travel at a
higher velocity and far more lethal than
routine bullets from five from a handgun
the damage they cause is a function of
the energy they impart as they pass
through the body
typical ar-15 bullet leaves the barrel
traveling almost three times faster and
imparting more than three times the
energy of a typical nine-millimeter
bullet from a handgun in the air fifteen
rifle outfitted with the magazine with
50 rounds allows many more lethal
bullets to be delivered quickly without
reloading
alright that's yeah it's a machine gun
I've seen a handful of ar-15 injuries my
career years ago I saw one from a man
shot in the back by a SWAT team the
injury along the path of the bullet from
the air 15 is vastly different from a
Louisville s velocity handgun the bull
okay I get it I get it
alright so there you go so there's that
[ __ ] viewpoint I feel like all of a
sudden doing like an NPR show here like
there's nothing funny anymore this is
all ar-15 stuff all right here's one
should we move to California hey Billy
leprechaun my girlfriend and I are sick
of the winters in Ontario half the year
it's cold snowy and gloomy my girlfriend
and I fantasize about moving somewhere
that's warm year-round should we move to
California is that all it's cracked up
to be
looking forward to seeing you in
Kitchener in March you know the grass is
always greener this sand is always brown
you know I don't think California needs
anybody else to move here it's really
overpopulated and there's a lot of
advantages to living where you're living
I been to Ontario a bunch of times it's
God's country up there I know it gets
cold in that type of [ __ ] but the fact
that you live where there's a water
supply you're not cutting I mean if you
want to just live in a constant state of
drought I always feel like when you live
in Los Angeles you're like eight years
ahead of the curve as far as like
environmental disasters because Los
Angeles is an environmental disaster
never should have existed we had to
steal water to be here and they're
building all these skyscrapers and you
know it was kind of nice for a minute or
a little bit after those [ __ ] banker
[ __ ] cooked the economy a bunch of
people left LA and now they're all being
driven back into the city and the we we
won we won the most congested city in
the United States and that's saying
something so if that's what you want to
become a part of San Francisco's more
expensive than New York City at this
point I got to tell you it's a
breathtakingly beautiful state though
when you go a little north of where I'm
at and if you can appreciate the desert
it desert is also very beautiful but to
be living in it is a little unsettling
if you read up on it but you know I'm in
the business I'm in so I got a [ __ ]
live out here I don't know what business
you're in but I don't know you know what
I would do I would just take an awesome
vacation every year with your girlfriend
and just break up the winner you know
take a week in like a weekend or like a
week whatever the [ __ ] you want to do
and just get the [ __ ] out of Dodge just
break it up - that's all you really need
to do because the trade-off is what
you're going to be doing is now you're
gonna live in a climate where it's like
people come here to go on vacation to go
out to like Santa Monica and [ __ ] so
[Music]
once you kind of live in with this palm
trees and [ __ ] which are not indigenous
to here I've learned it's not really
exciting to go to a lot of places after
that like oh wow this looks like where I
live you know I actually get excited by
the winter it's weird I don't know I
can't make these decisions for you I
don't know I don't [ __ ] III don't
pretend
No all right back to the gun [ __ ] and
this is the last time doing the gun [ __ ]
cuz I'm not just this is not going to
become the gun podcast I just find
people's opinions really interesting
here because I I don't you know i don't
i don't own guns and then type of [ __ ]
so i find it interesting
alright bill i own multiple err 15s i
hate that they are being used for mass
shootings contrary from what you hear
their best for use is for hunting mostly
varmints fox coyotes prairie dogs etc
now varmints is the proper word by the
way you send me sam ruined that word
that made it made everybody who uses the
word farm it sounded like a [ __ ] more
and let me look up the exact definition
here varmints varmint a troublesome wild
animal a troublesome image mischievous
person especially a child an animal
considered a pest specifically one
classified as vermin and unprotected by
game law varmint hunting is the practice
of hunting i hate when they do this of
vermin generally small mammals targeted
as a means of pest control rather than
for food varmint term may refer to a
varmint hunter or described hunting okay
so this guy's using this correctly
before everybody who you know you know
thinks this is you send me sam writing
it they are extremely accurate and have
very little recoil i'm able to shoot
holes in quarters at a hundred yards
jesus that's [ __ ] impressive they are
very fun to take to arrange and shoot
with that said at gun shows and stores
there's a really sad culture of losers
that talk about tactical situations like
their real life John Rambo's yeah
they're basically like the fantasy
football players you know acting like
they know how to run a [ __ ] football
team except their gun owners they
usually look like vermin a virgin
basement dwellers the thing a lot of
people don't understand about the ar-15
is that it's a modular rifle modular
rifle I buy them in parts and assemble
them on my own there's billions of
billions of parts that would be
available forever through private
parties to make more rifles they they
will never go away we need to get more
security in schools
there should be no way anyone should be
able to walk into a school with the gun
[Music]
there's okay so well then if you have a
metal detector at the school no one
could get in with the gun which sounds
good but then you know we used to
[ __ ] they just let you run around and
play outside the school before you went
in so wouldn't the kid just show up
there alright a metal detector on the
bus no I actually agree with that I
think that that would be smart okay
there's billions and billions of parts
of oh boy
Google Ruger mini-14 IT mini-14 it does
the same thing doesn't look scary the
problem isn't the guns my guns will
never be used for hunting humans in
Minnesota where I live to where I live
to get parts or complete ARS you have to
go to the County Sheriff and get a
permit to purchase card they take about
four weeks to get and have a pretty
stringent background check I think it
would be great if the entire country had
the same process I think the Second
Amendment is just as important as the
first I wish we could all have an honest
conversation about it I would say a calm
conversation about it the last one I'll
read here [ __ ] up country
hey there Billy strong Josh saw this on
reddit it's a story about how a 15 year
old girl with learning disabilities and
severe ADHD got in prison for throwing
apples at a mailman now went to prison
was sent to prison you mean she
continued to struggle with offers
officers through the entire process and
ended up doing five years until she hung
herself after the first shitty prison
transfer
transferred her to a federal prison for
women is this true this sounds [ __ ]
crazy
they interview a girl she knew in prison
who said she would talk back to the
guards because she thought it was funny
the whole time she was in there she
thought it was silly that she was in
prison for throwing apples whatever side
of the spectrum she's on she had the
mentality the whole time she was in
there she had that mentality whole time
she was in there at one point they put
her in this harness thing that is the
most ridiculous dehumanizing thing
you've ever seen as well as putting on a
hockey helmet so she couldn't swing her
head around while tied down because they
didn't want her to be a danger to
herself it's at the 12 33 mile I don't
know watch this it sounds horrible
anyways I'm thinking man our country
president system is [ __ ] up then they
said that it was somewhere in Ontario
and let me tell you Bill Canada hides
behind the shitty Prime Minister
Minister do-good douche who just said
the right thing all the time
meanwhile they had mental health
protocol wait meanwhile they had mental
health protocol than anything I've seen
in a duck you mean worse you kind of
left a word out about the US prison
system that I can recall fair enough
oh so Canada did all of this [ __ ] let me
see your clicking on the link what we've
got air
I I don't I don't want to do I don't
want to watch this I don't want to watch
it anyways alright well there we go so
that that's gonna be the end of the gun
debate on this [ __ ] podcast I don't
know I hope that people just understand
that people who live out in the air
quote middle of nowhere you know like
how they're living and how they have to
defend themselves is different than you
like living in a city you know and then
they can also go out and hunt and they
know how to hunt which is a you know
probably the most important skill you
could have you know if the [ __ ] hits the
fan the fact that you know how to [ __ ]
go out and get something to eat without
going to a soup I don't know I don't
know I think Reverend listen to all you
guys there has just have to have a
better system of I don't know how to do
it how do you how do you make sure how
do you make sure that crazy people don't
get guns so then regular people who just
want to enjoy them and [ __ ] hunt or
just shoot up a bunch of [ __ ] or
whatever or they just don't trust the
government which I don't think is
paranoid considering what has been done
to our food supply the pharmaceutical
companies bankers insurance companies
how they just kind of are able to do
whatever the [ __ ] they want to do and if
you really look at a lot of this [ __ ]
that they've done to this country it's
it's acts of terrorism that a lot of
terrorist groups would [ __ ] jerk off
to okay
poisoning the food supply you know
making Americans sick cooking the
economy all of that type of [ __ ] putting
[ __ ] in the water supply I mean that's
those are all terrorists that's [ __ ] the
terrorists [ __ ] jerk-off - so I
understand why people would not trust
their government at that [ __ ] point I
don't know I don't know what all I know
is that yeah after why
it gets overwhelmingly depressing and I
don't know what to do about it and and
that's it I'm gonna go play with my kid
and go play some drums that's it
god bless all you god bless all you're
responsible [ __ ] gun owners out there
god bless all you people out there feel
like f we just got rid of all of them
you know what god bless everyone and go
[ __ ] yourselves each and every one of
you those of you who have guns and those
of you who don't all right this has been
a [ __ ] [ __ ] to try to get to the
bottom of something and he failed
miserably I'll check on Thursday and I
got to start watching some Bruins games
I got to figure this out okay every
morning I'm watching puppy-dog pals in
vamp arena with my daughter maybe I can
get her watch a little maybe just maybe
I'll just start watching the first
period that's better than no period
right I'm [ __ ] all right I'll talk to
you on Thursday